Alhamdulillah.
forch.
[Silence]
The wording of these three verses are
very incredible.
The wording, the diction, meaning the
the choice of words,
the way that the verses are structured,
it is an incredible
style
of speech.
And anyone who reads the Quran
in Arabic
or reads its meanings in any other
language
enough to where they develop a feel for
it
will understand
that these are not the words of a human
being. It could never be the words of a
man.
No matter what Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us
[Silence]
he said
speaking to his prophet tell them if the
human race if all All of humanity, not
just present, but all of humanity from
Adam to the last pitiful soul upon which
the hour will be established.
If all of humanity and all of gankind
were to collaborate
in order to produce a recitation
similar to this recitation and similar
to this Quran, they would not be able to
do so. Even if they were all in
agreement and aided one another in doing
so.
Look at the structure of these three
verses. When we put them together with
the verses that came before them, this
is what the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
was first sent with. He was given the
tenants of Islam. the definition of
Islam. And we mentioned this definition
through these verses that the scholars
of Islam have
mind if you will and extrapolated
from the base text of the Quran and the
Sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. Notice the way that the words
are structured. Memorize these tenants.
This here is what we speak about when we
say seeking knowledge.
When we talk about seeking knowledge and
the importance of seeking knowledge and
the desperate need that the Muslim have
for scholars and scholarship.
When we speak about the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam saying that
the angels lower their wings and bow
their wings
out of admiration and respect and
exaltation for the one who seeks
knowledge.
This is what we're speaking about. It
doesn't have to be with a book. We
always imagine if I'm studying I have to
be in a university. If I'm no when the
prophet sallallam
said
he said seeking knowledge is an
obligation upon every Muslim.
This is what he was speaking about.
Sallallah.aii wasallam. The people
taking from the people of knowledge who
have taken from the people of knowledge
who have taken from the people of
knowledge who have taken from the
messenger of Allah.
Wasam the established tenants of Islam.
What doesallah
mean? What are its conditions? What
invalidates it? What does Muhammad
rasool Allah mean? What are its
conditions? What invalidates this
testimony? What depletes it? What
enhances it? What are the verses of the
Quran that we recite mean? What is the
definition of Islam? What is the
definition of im? Where is Allah? How
many angels are in the heavens and the
earth? what are the main most
important descriptions and names and
attributes of Allah Almighty etc. This
is what knowledge is and it's over time.
It takes time. But here for instance in
in our humble masid here for the past
almost 3 months we sit down together 10
minutes after fud 15 minutes on the
weekends. We sit down after isa 15
minutes every day five days a week. Look
how much knowledge has passed through
our hearts and minds in this very brief
amount of time. How many names of Allah
have we reviewed? How many descriptions
of Allah? How many narrations
have we discussed together between these
walls and under this ceiling? This is
what seeking knowledge is. It is not
that a person sits down and they hear a
nice inspirational story. That is great
and it has its place and we review the
stories of the prophets and messengers
and the companions and the people of
Islam but that is not the main priority
of knowledge. It's not entertainment.
This is a very serious endeavor that
people have to fight for. You have to
fight yourself for that. Even when a
person makes it to the masid and sits in
front of the student of knowledge or
sits in front of the sheh or sits in
front of the scholar even then a shaitan
is trying to stop him. The prophet the
companions
said
for
Allah. Subhanahu wa ta'ala. He said
sleepiness
when a person sits to learn Islam is
from a shan
and sleepiness just before a battle and
jihad is from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
as Allah mentioned in
in the opening verses of al
look at the way that the verses are
structured and remember and put that
together with the definition of Islam
that the scholars have refined and
extrapolated from these verses. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said,
"Oh you who is swaddled in his clothing,
stand and worn." Then the three tenants,
the definition of Islam
We said this is the definition of Islam.
He said,
"Exalt your Lord
and purify your deeds and your clothing
and abandon
idolatry and idols and the worship
thereof and anything having connection
to those idols, including the people of
idolatry." This is the definition of
Islam.
What is the definition of Islam? If we
say what is Islam?
We know that Gibl asked this same
question. He said what is Islam? And the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam defined
it as the shahada and establishing
prayer and giving zaka and fast and
Ramadan and Hajj. This is defining Islam
by its most prominent rights.
However, if we were to define Islam
specifically, not by its people, not by
its its tenants, but if we were to
define Islam by its root definition,
what is it?
[Silence]
notice
he's the the scholars of Islam they tell
us that Islam is defined as three main
things number one
it is submission to Allah
with.
Number two, it is adherence to Allah
with obedience.
Number three, it is disassociation
from shik and its people.
Those that is the definition of Islam.
Number one,
submission to Allah with
a person submits that none is rightfully
worshiped but Allah.
They they direct no type of worship to
other than Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
What are the types of and the types of
worship? Many. How do we learn them? You
have to learn them. You have to go out
of your way to learn them. It's not
something that is readily apparent
immediately.
The scholars tell us that when a person
becomes Muslim,
they walk through the threshold of the
door of Islam
when they sayahillahillham
and they take off their clothing of shik
and now they enter into Islam but they
are now naked.
They're still naked. All that you have
done when you become Muslim is purify
yourself from the worship of other than
Allah. You have entered into Islam. Now
you have to clothe yourself. You clothe
yourself with what? You clothe yourself
with the obedience of Allah. You clothe
yourself with knowledge of Allah and his
messenger sallall.aii wasallam.
Knowledge of that which you will be
asked about in your grave.
When monkar come to a person in their
grave and they sit him up and they ask
three questions. What are those three
questions? Who is your lord? Lord here
meaning who did you worship?
Who is your messenger?
Meaning who did you follow and emulate
in your path to Allah's mercy and
forgiveness and pleasure? What is your
religion? What law, what standard, what
code, what ethos, what creed did you
uphold in your life as the technology
between yourself and Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala? What were the scales of your
actions? The believer responds with his
actions.
A lot of people misunderstand
this point here and that is that a
person is put into his grave. Very
simple questions.
You can memorize those. We all know
that. Why is it so difficult to pass
this test? The answer is because you
don't answer those questions in the
grave.
You answer those questions before the
grave. When you put when you're put into
your grave, now you're only putting the
answers to your qu those questions into
words.
As Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said,
he says subhanahu wa ta'ala that on that
day enough of a witness over oneself as
his own self. Now bear witness to what
you did with your life. We right now you
and I right now we are answering the
questions of
right now. Every human being you pass in
the road, everyone you speak to,
everyone that is alive on the face of
this earth right now is answering those
three questions actively.
And they are preparing and furnishing
their grave either with fire or
pleasure. When a person is put into his
grave, he doesn't answer with what he
thinks.
He answers with what he did.
That's why the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam tells us
He said, "As for the hypocrite, what is
a hypocrite in Islam?" In Islam, the
definition, the root definition of
hypocrisy is
those who
give a facade,
exhibit Islam outwardly, but inwardly
they disbelieve in it. Now, people have
aspects of hypocrisy in them. Correct.
It is very difficult to purify yourself
of all traits of hypocrisy.
So he says saiam
the hypocrite or the wretched
the very wicked he will say
what does ha mean in Arabic? It's like
we in English we say when you don't
know something you say I it's
on the tip of my tongue. It's right
there. He then says, "I heard the people
saying something. I said it with them,
but I can't remember it right now.
[Silence]
said, "It will then be said to him, you
neither knew nor did you recite and
follow."
Then he will be struck with an iron
with an iron club that if a mountain
were struck with it, it would turn it to
dust.
And then he will scream and whail in
pain and terror and fear
that everything can hear except for the
human beings and the gin kind. It was a
well-known thing that when people had
animals,
this is mentioned in the history books
that kind of a kind of protip, right?
When you have an animal, a donkey, a
mule, a horse, whatever, that had a
problem, an infection in the bladder,
bladder infection. And so the bladder
would swell and the urinary tract would
swell and the animal couldn't urinate,
right? And so this is what is referred
to as insect, right? A kind of in
English you call it constipation, but
it's a a kind of fluid retention. They
would take the animals to the graveyards
of the disbelievers
and the animals would then
empty out their bladders out of horror
from what they were hearing going on in
those graves.
And so that is when we answer these
questions. We don't answer them in the
grave. In the grave, we just say what we
did. You answer with what you did, not
with what you know or have memorized.
And so these are the three aspects of
Islam. This is what builds Islam. What
is Islam?
Islam.
Memorize this. Teach your children.
Teach your family.
Submission to Allah with
an adherence to Allah's command with
holistic
obedience doesn't mean that you do
everything you try. There are those of
us who are better. There are those of us
who are lagging. However, there is a
holistic general obedience. When you
sayahillahillah changes your life,
changes your actions, changes your diet,
changes your thoughts, even if just a
little bit.
And
disassociation
from shik
and its people
and abandon
idolatry and idols. What do we mean when
we say disassociation from Shik and its
people? We're speaking about a religious
disassociation.
A religious disassociation.
Meaning that I love all Muslims. Those
of whom I've met and those of whom I
have not met. Those who came before us
and those who will come after us. Right?
This is a religious association.
Does it mean that I every single
Muslim on a personal level?
People have different personal quirks,
right? Maybe you feel someone is loud,
you feel someone is obnoxious, you don't
right, you don't necessarily like
everyone on a personal level, but a
religious love and allegiance to every
Muslim. That is what is meant by
disassociation from Shik and its people.
That allegiance is only for the Muslim.
forch.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.